[Music]
AET what's up this is Sean Paul
alongside via girl Becky G and we on the
set of my love that's my new single
featuring David Guetta and Becky G come
check it out
[Music]
we're here on the set of the music video
explain to me the concept colourful
hello it's sexy it's hot I think it
channel's the energy that the song kind
of makes you feel it's magic when the
two of you come together talk to me
about this collaboration who contacted
who well he's just been selling at me
and I get I've been working out for a
while and Becky was up for that scene
how she
yeah they see how she sounds on it and
to me I was like that's that's a winner
she's a triple threat as they call it
she could sing she could dance you know
I mean she looks amazing
I've got one of the most iconic artists
standing right next to me he's super
humble and so talented and immediate
like chemistry about the song about
everything just excitement and to have
his support means everything to me
since we're here on set of the Mad Love
music video I want to know a couple of
things who's got the bigger entourage I
think I think we're pretty equal today I
would say him he went you know I don't I
don't know probably myself as a as an
entourage dude come on come on who's
here with you guys today well Jules
she's my management Richie you know
security at a bit that's basically my
mom she keeps it real if I look good on
camera she's like you gotta get a girl
and then when I don't she's like you
better work come out cuz you don't have
nobody bringing you pink popcorn no yes
who's got the better dance moves we got
different vibes you know he's got a
swaggy chill little rock with it you
know and then I'm over here like yeah
yeah sexiness overall still intelligent
and she taught me a few things today
what yes teach me something because new
way anywhere like Warner
mad love you know you need it in life
not just on the dance floor but you need
it from those around you is there a
celebrity when you were first starting
that really just kind of showed you mad
love and got behind your career and like
made you feel good when I first did
songs with Busta Rhymes that was amazing
for me we did science together so it was
kind of like a lot of his fans knew who
I was instantly Jennifer really early on
gave me that like the blessing of like
all right young latina coming up the
hood on the rise got a got a support
ready for a next hot fire Kawai I'm
ready
Becky from the block 2.0 yo you see
that's a wrap
we out of here love not blow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]